simplifica la expresión 28 por a
cuadrado por b a las 6 entre 7 x a la 9
por ver que ahí queremos simplificar
esta expresión y pues una buena forma de
empezar es dividir esta expresión en
términos que nosotros ya sabemos que se
pueden simplificar más fácilmente por
ejemplo nosotros ya sabemos que 28 es
divisible entre 7 y entonces nos va a
quedar un entero que es más simple que
una fracción entonces lo primero que
vamos a hacer es separar este 28 entre 7
aunque pongámoslo por aquí 28 entre 7
eso está multiplicando al resto de la
expresión pero este pedazo lo podemos
partir en otros dos pedazos que son más
fáciles de simplificar ok podemos tomar
este pedazo entonces lo vamos a poner
por aquí que es a cuadrado entre a al 9
y el último pedazo que nos queda es este
pedazo de aquí que es
a las 6 entre b
esto es exactamente igual a esto de aquí
y la razón por la que hicimos todo esto
es porque cada una de estas fracciones
es muy fácil de simplificar aquí hay 28
entre 7 sabemos que es igual a 4 y aquí
lo que tenemos son dos exponentes con
exactamente la misma base y la base es a
entonces para hacer esta división lo que
hacemos es poner la misma base que es a
tomar la potencia del numerador que es
este 2 y restarle la potencia del
denominador que es este 9 aunque
entonces tenemos 2 menos 9 y 2 menos
nueve pues es menos
y lo mismo pasa con este término porque
ahí tenemos a las 6 entre b elevado a la
potencia 1 aunque aunque aquí no se vea
estévez está elevado a la potencia 1 así
es que si dividimos b elevado a las 6
entre b elevado a la 1 lo que obtenemos
es b elevado a las seis menos uno que es
5 y listo hemos terminado ya
simplificamos esta expresión y su forma
simplificada es esta de aquí claro que
podría no gustar nos tener exponentes
negativos entonces vamos a reescribir
esto como el 4 lo dejamos igual
él ha elevado a la menos 7 es igual a 1
/ ha elevado a las 7 y nos falta
multiplicar por b elevado a las 5 que ya
su vez esto también es igual a 4 por b
elevado a las 5 / ha elevado a las 7